omelets are a satisfying show-stopping
way of upgrading your breakfast game and
odds are you already have everything you
need to create one they say you can't
make an omelet without breaking a few
eggs well we cracked hundreds to test
the best tips tricks and techniques so
we could show you our recipes for the
three most essential omelettes
[Music]
first up the french omelet
to some the french omelet is arguably
the most famous and technically
challenging
soft on the outside and custardy on the
inside this omelet is easier to make
than most people think there are only
four ingredients in this recipe so it's
really important that they're the
freshest you can find especially the
eggs as eggs get old the membrane inside
slowly breaks down becoming more liquidy
resulting in a flatter and sadder omelet
fresher eggs have a more robust interior
making the omelette even fluffier
start by cracking your eggs in a large
bowl don't worry if you see any of these
white stringy bits
also known as the kaleise
they're totally normal and won't affect
the taste or texture of your omelet
you want to beat the eggs until they're
completely combined you don't want to
see any stringy bits of yolk or white
floating around
whisk whisk whisk
next we're adding water
as the omelet cooks the water will
become steam allowing it to rise
when tested the omelet with the water
was noticeably fluffier than both the
one without water
and the one with cold butter added while
cooking
lastly add the salt and whisk again
let the mixture stand for about 10 to 15
minutes to allow the salt to work its
magic as the salt dissolves a couple
things start happening it evenly
distributes throughout giving the
omelette consistent seasoning and helps
give it a fluffy texture
just a heads up your eggs may get deeper
in color this is totally normal if
anything it'll actually make the
omelette look even better
like instagram worthy you know what i'm
saying
make sure you choose a pristine
non-stick pan eggs are notoriously
sticky if given the chance classically
french omelets are made over high heat
but we found medium is actually much
better for beginners and yielded
similarly delicious results add the
butter and just let it do its thing
until it just barely starts to foam like
with the eggs make sure to use good
unsalted butter we recommend european
style which has a higher fat content
remember more fat means more flavor
also this is a french omelet so you know
staying in line the next bit requires
some coordination add the eggs to the
pan while using a spatula to scrape the
curds up from the bottom and the sides
you want to keep moving them around so
that they stay on the smaller side
remember smaller curds
better omelette in a few minutes the
eggs will become softly scrambled and
custardy reduce the heat to low and use
in your spatula gently spread everything
into an even layer
if there are any pools of undercooked
egg give the pan a gentle shake to
distribute them everything should be wet
not runny and hold its shape
with the heat turned off slowly and
carefully roll the omelette up adding a
bit of butter to the pan so the eggs
unstick more easily it's a little pro
tip for you
once completely rolled make sure the
seam side is facing down so everything
is sealed up this might sound excessive
but brush the omelette with even more
butter this gives it a glossy appearance
and makes the surface sticky enough for
garnishes to adhere to it i mean again
french omelet french butter more butter
it's a whole vibe
we prefer ours with the classic
combination of fresh chives and flaky
sea salt
and voila you've made a french omelet a
word of advice don't waste any time it's
best enjoyed fresh out of the pan
the interior should still be creamy and
custardy and with a little bit of
practice you can become a master in no
time
the american omelet the american almond
the american omelet the american omnic
okay let's talk about american omelets
so maybe you want an omelette that's a
little bit less fussy or maybe you just
want to add a ton of toppings golden
brown on the outside packed with flavor
on the inside the american style
omelette is the one for you to get
started like with the french omelet we
found that salting the eggs ahead of
time greatly improved the fluffiness
factor we also found that water had a
significant impact on texture other
additives like cream actually give the
omelette a significantly denser texture
who would have thought
beat the mixture until well combined
then set aside for 10 to 15 minutes
while the eggs rest let's talk about
toppings the best part the ratio is key
we found that a quarter cup of cooked
filling for two eggs works best
you can use whatever ingredients you
want just remember some fillings like
spinach or mushrooms contain more water
than others so it's important to cook
them down to prevent the omelet from
getting too loose and watery in a pan
over medium-high heat add the butter
once melted add the vegetables and cook
until softened
we're going with a classic combination
of onions and peppers
finally if using add your choice of meat
we went with ham and cook until browned
and crispy
transfer the toppings to a bowl and set
aside
make sure to give the pan a good wipe to
remove any burnt or sticky bits that you
know could mess with your omelette
add the butter and let it cook until
browned and nutty this is what's going
to give the omelet a lot of its
trademark golden brown crust
add the eggs to the pan
as they begin to set use the spatula to
push them from the edge to the center
tipping the pan as needed to allow the
mixture to spread and cook evenly the
curds should be larger than those in the
french omelet you can tell it's ready
when the eggs are set but the top still
appears wet turn off the heat then add
the toppings over the egg finishing it
off with your choice of cheese we went
with a nice cheddar
cover the pan with a lid and let
everything stand for a minute or two
while the residual heat finishes the
omelet and melts the cheese
oh yum
finally loosen and fold the omelet in
half and transfer to a plate to serve
and there you have it that's how to make
an american style omelette it should be
golden brown on the outside with a
cheesy fluffy interior
it's delicious it's filling
it's pretty hard to beat
but we're not quite done yet
the japanese omelet tamagoyaki
if you've never tried a japanese omelet
prepare to have your mind blown while
some people spend years perfecting this
artful omelet with a bit of practice
you'll be rolling this at home in no
time start by beating the eggs until
they're well combined but not overbeaten
to the point of being bubbly or frothy
next add the sugar
salt
soy sauce and mirin you can also use
sake feel free to adjust the amounts
depending on how sweet or savory you
want the omelet to be we prefer a
balance somewhere in the middle
dashi stock adds a ton of umami to the
omelet we use powdered dashi which only
needs water
a word of caution don't add too much or
the eggs will become too delicate to
handle making them really challenging to
roll we found our sweet spot to be about
1 tablespoon of dashi per egg
add the doshi stock and whisk everything
together until incorporated
a quick pro tip transfer the mixture to
a measuring cup to make it easier to
pour while cooking
or you know you could also just whisk it
in one to begin with
normally japanese omelettes are made
using a purpose-built pan which we
easily found on amazon the square
configuration makes it ideal for rolling
the omelette into its iconic shape
however a normal non-stick fry pan works
just as well you'll just need to trim
the edges the omelet once all is said
and done that part's really easy set the
pan over medium-high heat once a
temperature brush generously with oil
using chopstick and a folded piece of
paper towel make sure to get those
corners too you could also totally use a
silicone brush
don't skimp on the oil make sure the pan
is totally coated
add enough egg to coat the bottom of the
pan swirling it around to create an even
layer it should also sizzle and bubble a
little when first added but the heat
shouldn't be so high that the eggs brown
if your omelet starts to brown you've
gone too far
just start over it's fine
and a word of advice if your pan is too
hot rather than fiddle with the stove
controls raise and lower the pan off the
heat to keep everything from overcooking
just make sure things don't get too cool
or else the egg will stick to the pan
when the bottom of the eggs are set and
the top is still a bit wet you know it's
ready to roll gently start rolling the
egg towards yourself if it tears a bit
that's okay don't worry these will
disappear as you continue layering the
egg once fully rolled push it to the
opposite side of the pan keep repeating
each step oiling pouring setting rolling
and pushing until all the egg mixture is
used up by this point the omelet should
resemble its final form we prefer to
slice ours into quarters look at all
those amazing layers they're so pretty
you can really see every layer it's kind
of like a little mini crepe cake
serve it with a bit of grated daikon
radish and some soy sauce the perfect
japanese omelet should be boxy pale
yellow with a custardy spiral of egg
throughout its center
perfect for impressing guests or
most importantly yourself and there you
have it the three essential omelettes
every cook should have in their roster
whether it's the classic french omelet
the fulfilling american omelette or the
beautiful japanese omelet you're now
guaranteed to have a stellar recipe for
any occasion what's your perfect
omelette let us know in the comments
below these recipes are all available on
tasty.com
oof my perfect omelet when i was little
my mom would make i guess i don't know i
guess it's a combo between like a french
and american but she would layer like
sour cream and scallions and paprika
maybe that sounds like a weird combo but
it's the best when i make an omelette
that's all i want on it